joe biden says the u.s would intervene
with military to defend taiwan
the ap reports president joe biden said
monday the u.s would intervene
militarily if china were to invade
taiwan declaring the commitment to
protect the island is even stronger
after russia's invasion of ukraine quote
as i'm quoting the ap here it was one of
the most forceful presidential
statements in support of taiwan's
self-governing in decades
wow talk about strength from our leader
joe biden
in fact so strong that bloomberg reports
biden misspeaks on taiwan
says u.s military would intervene oh
you know i love
they they're they try to cover for him
so much they don't know which direction
to go so the ap is like what a forceful
statement like no he was gaffing and
then bloomberg is like he was
misspeaking yo he literally said one
word yes he was asked would the u.s use
military uh intervene with military to
defend taiwan from china and biden goes
yes and there and then the report was
like
really
wow yeah okay
everyone was surprised joe biden just
came out and just said that effectively
ending multi-decade-long uh policy on
how the u.s approaches china and
basically just telling china to go screw
up so
look if
if someone who was cognitively
functioning said yes i'd be like whoa
but i think what really happened is we
know the us does want to intervene with
military in the event china invades
taiwan but nobody's going to come out
and say it but you know joe biden is sun
setting so it's like it's getting late
in the day and he's like
and then they say and he just his
filter's off yes
and then immediately an unnamed white
house official walks it back saying
that's not true we wouldn't do this and
we we have the one china policy that
hasn't changed i see all this reporting
coming from cnn and these these these
reporters coming up being like the white
house actually says and then i'm like
who
who cnn comes out and covers for the
president it's not true he didn't mean
it bloomberg covers for the president
saying he was misspeaking and the ap
covers for the president saying it was a
truly forceful statement
yeah we're gaffing towards world war iii
and just
it's almost like it's dangerous to have
a nice by the way it's almost like it's
dangerous to have a president who's
experiencing cognitive decline you know
i think there's only one way to bring
this administration back and that's for
joe biden to become the first celebrity
endorsement of neurolink
once that happens
then we can go forward and of course
you know as much as i oppose pretty much
everything that elon musk is about aside
from this free speech and the chicks uh
i think that um you know he would
probably bring it back around if he
could tweak the neuro link to start
making biden say ridiculous things more
ridiculous things than he does now for
instance if you could have him turn to
nancy pelosi and say that your your hair
looks like it smells so delicious yeah
come on man i smell dance's hair
but i i agree like if there's anybody
who should get neural and gets joe biden
he needs some kind the upper is clearly
not working anymore maybe this is the uh
the kind of like the missing footage
from idiocracy you know before
everything goes down world war iii wipes
out all the rest of the smart people due
to some re ridiculous president no no we
all get on elon musk's starship and
leave
how many people can that thing hold do
we know
no i don't know anything about it no
starship let's find out that starship
for like a mars colony or something you
guys enjoy
no well i mean if the earth is about to
explode yeah absolutely i was just
thinking mars has like what a third of
earth's gravity oh mars can't sustain it
that's what's that going to what's going
to do underground
it's going under underground yeah well
the issue is mars my understanding
doesn't have an atmosphere
so we'd be living in domes like you know
biodome like with paulie shorma or that
movie oh yeah you know steve bannon
worked on the original biodome
like the real one yep
absolutely in the real world not the
poly shore movie no the real one in the
real world okay uh it's it's it's
fascinating
i just saw an article about quantum uh
some sort of quantum telescopes that can
check underground and like map the
underground now all the caverns and
stuff so maybe we'll do that on mars
i was just thinking about biden a couple
days ago i was back at my parents i was
kind of off the off the internet
thinking like
if you have a military commander that's
incompetent or that's losing his mind or
her mind you need to replace them
immediately with with another form of
command unfortunately the president's a
little awkward situation because it's
not like a general you're you're a
commanding general um but i would be so
much happier with kamala harris running
the show right now because he's not
stable no no she's an ai auto predict
tech spot it surely is i mean we it's
funny because it's a joke because of
like a few gaffes she's had but when you
really look at what she said it it she's
not speaking it's like she sits down
and she's imagining what's going on in
her head as she's being interviewed and
she's like don't screw up don't screw up
say words say words you did it those are
words and she's not actually telling
anybody anything she's like as the vice
president you have to be vice
presidential to be the vice president on
a vice presidential mission for the vice
president you're like okay okay what
well say what you want the woman stands
for freedom she does that that's true
yeah i was looking at
waiting for them to use that one yeah no
no no
it's it's the yeah you're right i wrote
that a couple days ago i was like i hope
i can say this on tim cast i was looking
at the the succession the other day and
um you know one hard bout of covid or
maybe monkey pox at this point and uh
you would take out biden pelosi and i
think it's leahey and then boom you're
left with harris and blinken
imagine a world like that that's
probably why they're so worried about
every new thing that's popping up
because they're i mean let's be real
like covet was it was primarily hitting
older people even bill gates says so so
naturally yeah they were freaking out
it's probably why nancy pelosi was like
everyone's got to wear a mask no matter
what because she's in the affected group
that means what is she 80 yeah yeah she
that's like the highest bracket for
covid so and joe biden too i mean
seriously though look we don't want
anybody getting sick or anything but
like you can't you can't freak out or i
should put it this way it goes to show
why it is really dangerous to have these
elderly veterinarians oh yeah
octogenarians yeah she's 82
82.
they just they just won't that you know
they they they've like gripped on to
power and they won't let it go they're
like those things on ship's holes it's
like gollum barnacles they're they're
old barnacles and we're stuck with them
i i'd imagine congress is more like a
bunch of gollum from lord of the rings
you know they want the power they won't
give it up true they're all like their
teeth have fallen out and their hair's
gone i mean it i'm not kidding the
comparison holds up it feels so
intricately entrenched like i'm very
concerned about how to fix the situation
with the united states because i'm like
the corporations don't own us we own
corporations the united states are
people sovereign and people on twitter
are like no the corporations own us ian
and like come on purge the black pill we
can take control but like they're so
entrenched these these 80 year old
billionaires or millionaires with these
people that are like klaus i don't know
how tight nancy pelosi and klaus schwab
are i'm just using names right now but
people that are like
multi-national bankers are tight with
these 80 year old politicians and
they've been tight for like 30 years how
do you destroy or disrupt that web
how would you disrupt that web is it
technological is this the where the the
the future of technology is headed you
know that's a hard question to throw at
me right away uh how do you fix it all
uh do you do with technology give us the
answers otherwise you don't have
credibility yeah um you know i have a
answer but i think that most of our
solutions lie regionally locally i i
don't think that um any mass movement is
necessarily going to stop this this
corporate technocratic
takeover that we've seen really arguably
since the 60s people put the date
different places uh and i it does have
such a momentum at this point that uh to
me
i think the notion of just stopping it
like a train is pretty ridiculous i
think that the the best options we have
right now lie with ourselves it's very
unwise to look to a higher earthly power
for salvation in this situation
yeah well i think the question is how do
we break it apart i agree
heavily that we need localized solutions
i think a big part of this is people
looking after their own lives their
families obviously it would be ideal to
return power to more local levels but
then the question becomes how do we
break up the very strongly centralized
power so that becomes more possible
anti-trust i mean and that that
definitely has an impact right that
slows the train
but when you're talking about to me i
take a profoundly negative view of the
uh
wider possibilities of technology i
think that you know in the end
technology is always about control
and
conceivably it's about a human
controlling nature controlling society
controlling themselves but that means
that the vast swath of human kind is
going to be subject to that control and
the desire for that power the
capabilities that we already have now
that you already see in google facebook
amazon
this already has momentum that you break
them up
great you've at least diminished some of
their power but i think that ultimately
long view we've got to go down the dark
dark tunnel before we get to the light
you mean like ayahuasca journeys where
people like see their inner demons and
stuff
you know it doesn't take ayahuasca for
me to see the inner demons but
now that you mention it
no we won't go there no it's bad for my
brain i think uh culture building
you know so i've had a lot of
conversations this past weekend was on a
trip was in austin by the way that was
fun talk to a lot of cool people and the
one thing i think you know i always come
back to is
you can build all the greatest tech in
the world you can vote whoever you want
to power none of that matters unless you
have culture
so you know we talk about uh
the saying i think was breitbart
politics is downstream from culture
technology i think uh is as well
but technology i don't think is is as
important i know you've had you've said
the universe ian before
but uh the issue is
there exists alternative to twitter
nobody uses it why it's cultural issues
you know people don't want to use
alternatives they want to be on the
platform where everyone is
so if you
culture is everything i'll put it that
way if we can start inspiring young
people and say these are the values that
that are good and you should hold
everything else becomes secondary as
those kids age everything else gets
washed away with the new generation so
it really is about inspiring young
people with good values is the most
powerful and important thing you can do
to fix these problems one of the things
i noticed being out of town and on the
road i was just not tapped into the
information and it was like i realized
the amount of information overload i've
been exposed to in the last two years
and how how clear things started to get
when i wasn't exposed to twitter and
then even if i pulled up for five
minutes i start to feel this negative
dark negativity and i'd see a few people
arguing and like man i'm gonna have to
withdraw that from my brain for a while
that might have something to do with the
darkness which actually isn't evil like
too much light will burn you so you need
to sometimes have no thought what was it
uh jack dorsey called twitter the light
of global consciousness
very spiritual claim he said that he was
something to the effect he's happy to
pass the torch of the light of global
consciousness to elon musk and this
concept of twitter being
something mystical of that sort i mean
that sits at the heart of transhumanism
but uh to me i you know you look at this
this argument people are having right
now about free speech on twitter which i
i do think it's good that if we are
going to be stuck in what james poulos
calls the the cyborg vivarium at least
everyone gets to say but it doesn't
change the fact that we're still stuck
in that cyborg by bivarium right we're
still
in a digital surveillance system we're
in a
basically a 24 7 propaganda machine
that's pouring all this irrelevant
ultimately irrelevant information into
your brain and distracting you from what
i think are the most important things i
think it's just us here all this started
with broadcast media i mean radio
absolutely of course the newspapers even
before then it was newspapers were weak
they weren't as strong but they were the
most influential medium so they would
write stuff people would believe it then
you get radio they say people believe it
and then you get broadcast towers
television the networks they say it
people believe it now with the internet
nobody knows what to believe
i mean the disinformation expert herself
was sewing disinformation and now
doesn't even under i don't think nina
jacob was even truly understood exactly
why people were mad at her because she
lives in a disinformation bubble herself
so i i love it when
people who don't do research accuse
people who do of not knowing you know
the truth or reality and everyone's
accusing each other there are very few
people who can see more than others
because they're trying no one can see
everything so everybody's you know we're
all trying to figure things out
but i think at this point the way
technology is going
you're just going to think something's
true
and you're not going to know who to
believe or who to trust and there's
nothing you can do about it did you guys
hear the war of the world's 1938 radio
drama oh yes orson welles familiar with
it i never actually listened it's pretty
wild it's awesome actually i was told
that when that played on the radio
people actually thought it was real and
that aliens were actually invading and
people killed themselves some people
people would come out looking forward to
true that was it was apocryphal yeah it
could have been that's like an urban may
have been high certainly there was mass
panic uh you know i can remember when i
was uh a young man my grandfather told
me that when the first dirigible it was
like a glow a glowing golden derigible
floated over this small town in georgia
this woman went under her bed she
thought it was you know the angels
coming to in the world and two or three
days later they found her there like you
know they looked around for they found
her there and she was completely
terrified she didn't want to come out
these sorts of things i mean you look at
the cargo cults uh you know all these
sorts of uh you could say
atavistic misinterpretations of what
technology really is that's really
common um with the orson welles story
though i think it's just really
hilarious can you imagine if they just
played cloverfield on television today
like it was a news broadcast without
telling people it was a movie well the
crazy thing is uh so i when i was in
austin i went to waco i actually went to
mount carmel where the uh that's the
site of the waco massacre
and uh you know with all due respect to
the people who are running it very nice
woman they did have fake news they had
the meme of what was the name chipman
the atf guy who was there
holding the picture of the burning
church or whatever which is not a real
photograph
it's a meme mocking him he was holding
his paper saying like you know ama or
something i don't know and then someone
photoshopped it to be him holding the
the site of you know mount carmel
massacre wicca massacre and they thought
it was real
and so i was like oh actually no that's
a meme's making fun of them and they're
like oh we didn't know that so people
deep fakes very much are impacting
people and i don't mean defects in the
sense that they're intentionally
misleading like
no wonder snopes is fact checking satire
because a lot of people just believe
this stuff because they don't know
what's true or what's what's false
it's it's fascinating because i think
false information is a big problem in
fact it is one of the biggest problems
and i would dare say that my entire
career is an effort to try and debunk
false information
the only problem is it's coming from
corporate press with billions or
trillions of dollars over you know a
decade or whatever to just keep pumping
out disinformation sometimes it feels
like you're trying to knock on a
skyscraper with a little hammer a little
ball peen hammer you can't do it it's
not going to happen
specialized tools what you can do as you
were talking about you can cultivate
spaces outside of it which you know we
have those
i'm not necessarily saying the digital
spaces but that's part of it but i think
that at least half the country if not
more is completely cynical about what
comes out of the corporate press and in
those conversations on the ground and
also in the media digital media space i
do see a real hope of people having some
degree of anchoring or sanity in all of
this this madness thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you